what steps can I write or take to make a
three-dimensional character oh good I
think you got to start thinking about
who they are physically emotionally
socially you got to figure out what
their vulnerabilities are what their
flaws are what they're good at what
they're not good at what their
insecurities are because we're all
motivated by that we're motivated by our
insecurities people do things because
they're trying to feed whatever hole is
on the inside of them so I do a whole
trauma and stress lesson during my no
writer's block course because every one
of us has a trauma even if your trauma
may seem small to me and my trauma may
seem small to you we each have a trauma
and on some level that trauma created
our insecurities and our insecurities is
what feeds us that's our motivation so I
always give the example of the
characters in The Wizard of Oz because
the lion is cowardly
he says if I can get Dorothy to Oz then
I am NOT a coward because what I have to
go through makes me brave it's not
because he really cares about Dorothy he
wants to take her office you know what I
mean it's because he's a coward and so
at some point he has to decide okay in
order to be brave and get rid of the
Cowardly stuff and I got to go through
something that gets me there so that's
the thing that motivates you know him to
actually do the external thing so that
internal thing is really the motivator
for the external thing and so I feel
like that's true for people and if we
realize that about people then we
realize that about characters and then
that's how they become that's how they
get depth and they become more
believable well if we go back to Harry
Potter what what are some of his wounds
that then show up and we so his biggest
wound is identity right he's he's not
being raised by his parents so that's in
and of itself going to be a trauma
whether you knew it him he knew he
always knew that these weren't his
parents so that's something that has
always been inside him all of the time
some people don't find that information
that until later and then the trauma
starts right but for him he always knew
these are not my people
on top of that the people who were
raising him were mistreating him and
abuse
using him so that's a second trauma and
then on top of that he's a weirdo who
can hear snakes talking and sometimes
make things disappear and so all he's
thinking is I'm this other that no one
loves so I think that's one of the
reasons he has a hero complex that he
has to save other people and always be
looking that's why his friends are so
important to him and why he has to save
people because of that whole of identity
of Who am I who loves me who do I love
back and where do I belong
how do we get a viewer to care about a
character I think it goes back to that
same stuff like if I can understand why
you do what you're doing
then that's gonna be far more relatable
because we're almost all of us are are
working from that same kind of place
right so for example if I am always
seeing a person being lazy it's easy for
me to just assume or they're lazy but if
I understand that really they're
overwhelmed and they want to be a they
don't know where to start and they want
to be able to ask questions but don't
know what question to ask so they're
really frozen in that spot and not being
lazy that I can understand now I've been
in a place where it's like yo I need
some information but I don't even know
where to begin
for whatever reason I've been equipped
to then figure it out maybe this person
hasn't so maybe I now have a different
perspective of who that person is by
understanding that they're just frozen
in time because they don't know which
way to go because they don't have those
kind of skills to do so now they're not
lazy they're overwhelmed I think all of
us can relate to over whelmed people
more so than we can relate to a lazy
person it seems like there's so many
films with great production value
especially now but sometimes there's a
disconnect with the character so this
goes back to how come we're not always
caring about these characters but the
world looks great there's just something
missing about our emotional connection
yeah if that if that kind of thing
happens and I would definitely say it's
probably something that happen
writing it's probably something that's
not on the on the page to attach that
emotional journey to the physical
journey and so we're missing out on it
sometimes that happens purposefully
because they were more excited about the
world and they were more excited about
the production value and that's what
they wanted to give you and they figured
that part would be the thing that makes
you excited about it and sometimes that
happens you know sometimes people
depending upon what they're making who's
making it why they're making it who has
the money to throw at it it may just be
I want to tell this big you know fantasy
story and that's the part that matters
so that's what you get it just really
depends again going back to those
executives who have now decided to
purchase the script and take it into
development if they care about the
characters then it's gonna get pulled
out if they don't it might not you know
if the brand of the place is you just
want to make big you know slasher films
that don't that you don't care about the
people you people just die then they're
not gonna spend time on trying to make
you like them they're gonna give you
just one or two things there so that you
know that this is the good guy and you
know the slasher is the bad guy and then
they're just gonna make a movie so it
just really depends on what what they're
trying to get across you know when
they're when they're doing it but
definitely if you're not able to
emotionally connect then something
happen in the writing the question is
why was it allowed
you